so just to make it a little bit easier
you have to do this but just make it
easier to see I'm going to introduce a
substitution maybe you wouldn't follow
along if you're doing especially me as
well right if I introduce this and it
makes just a little bit easier to write
and socialize and see what to do with it
so I've got three plugs you - - you
sweat okay so now it's clear add a
return a we look question into
impression I'd know how to do this it's
just a quadratic
I'm a multiplexer my negative one
because I don't like negative values for
that first coefficient what do I do with
this what can I do it a pair of numbers
of my own people 3 and surely one of
those mystery negative 3/2 emoji
interestingly now because it W is
negative on the numbers are just 2 and
minus 3
you know what I do with two a monster
returns okay so this becomes a different
you have to do oh I'm probably do it
let's see this let's go this way
- you two versus three or two this is a
variety of this is one of a variety of
things that you could do so next you can
see where I've used the 200 minus 3
there for twos there and I'm dividing by
2 because I want this video to you
squared not a or you square are the two
goes into one of these which one the
first one right
just do a quick metal check does that
check out did that expand back to the
original thing mm-hmm
you're going to get to your square
Dungey you're going to get minus 3 and
then you have a look at the use in the
middle the other plus 2 your my to you
happy so 5 what do I do this I'm you
there like in Seoul for you that's why I
factorize right so U is going to be
negative 1 or very good okay so at this
point I've solved for you but U is just
a stadium potatoes so at this point I'm
going to write two different equations
I'm going to write this one and this one
now the first one has an exact value on
it the first one had get exact value if
you're lazy you can go to your
calculator and when you put in they run
shifted negative one you're going to get
out pretty sure negative 45 degrees
negative 45 degrees and a teeny little
catch with that solution with negative
point five degrees what's the catch
outside the domain let me deal that's
okay if negative 45 degrees is a
solution there it is and I can take
advantage of the fact that 10 is a
periodic function just like every other
two punch so if I go forward a set
amount I'm going to get a non solution I
go forward assess none what sir that's
that a period of 10 is looking to
increase if I go 480 what now you will
that be wasn't 35 so then one of my
solution that inside the domain but I
can keep playing this trick right I can
do for the another one degree degrees if
I go forward again what would I tell you
to what I'm looking to if I added
related is the pretty sure I did
315 degree unite at really soothing and
that's also in the domain you do that
they both good solutions all right good
for those down
that X can be 135 or 315 so that's from
here but then you've got another set of
solutions the top of the stack equation
okay throw to that select X values so
what he gives you what you can do okay
reach for your calculator go ahead I'm
you got a calculator then am I going to
be forward to it or you guys inside come
on just got 59 all right nice I just saw
the number of house right 956
can I get minute 90 just how do you want
a seconds you so I said you know okay
great
search your calculator told you this by
the way by the way you know i said i'll
technically presented for that's exactly
are you I sort of got the folketing with
maybe 45 because it's related to this
guy right you should remember that one
you should remember the edges 45 I don't
you don't need to remember again
calculate up you have your answer sheet
or one but it's such a common value that
you want to get for it do you see that
this gives us s check for this context
industry on two pieces if that's 45
degrees there's one right so tan x
equals one tan x equals one will give
you 45 degrees agree thrift is just a
little further up right he is 302 doing
one and a half right so when you go
everybody you should see oh yeah I
should be just a little bit past point
by the great a stern up as a network got
50 sin series item X there's one of you
solutions but I'm going to play exactly
the same trick I did before because here
is periodic so I'll have another
solution namely
that plus what a right which I can do in
my head that suit outside is 236 and 19
minutes yes they'd rather just to be
really nice to me I think will be ideal
at the end to tie up everything in a
loose boat and do a nice knot and put
all four of your solutions one two three
four in a row in ideal circumstances
you'd put them in ascending order but it
doesn't really matter what does matter
is that you have everything the reason
why I put this out is because suppose
this is a different question instead of
can that website okay just suppose it
means was the original question what's
this thing sorry if this is the original
question right everything about the way
that I just solved this question would
still apply
pretty much everything except that when
I get down to see how I'll get rid of
the technoscience whatever I will
effectively use once I get down to here
right my lines will just be sizes that
attain so eventually I'll come down to
this
okay now play this game with me again
I've got carrot equations I want to
solve you two so have a look at the
first one again they're the exam value
that goes through this can you remember
okay so I go to just like I'd showed you
before is to either bigger to ground
right that everything is why bigger than
ago in this case to be bigger ground
where negative one on this graph then
one they're negative one so where did
this graph equal negative one and some
of you one spot right there that's 270
years right so I'm going to say x equals
270 will stop then you have to look at
the other part the other kind of dosages
when you assign X equal to one and a
half we said that's one right so we're
one the heart is somewhere out there
isn't it 302 when in that when sinx
collided with that line it's a there
bump right so what you get pretty arm is
no solution let's yeah at this way I
think that was real right x equals 230
degrees and then there's a solution like
which in it and the point is you get no
solution from here but you do get
solutions from here so therefore I would
say this now I've seen a lot of students
they'll write this down and I said cool
I get three teachers but write this down
and then they will ignore it
because they go through that thought
process we just went through our
thoughts on that and so they don't dry
it down but that's actually important
part of the process is a solution that
should come from that but you have to go
in there valid so this is a nice
immediate way to say it which is why I
tend to write my final y
including both or all of my branches in
case this morning - okay so there's the
business